no
no moon it was it was halfway there and
then it took a u-turn
i forgot my keys yeah
[Music]
actually yeah it was elon and uh
saturday night live really tanked
bitcoin
that sucks did they really i'm surprised
that he did that because he's such a big
guy involved with bitcoin yeah no he
said it wasn't
uh it wasn't energy environmental oh
yeah environmentally friendly the way
they
mine it the carb computer processing but
but he did shout out dope coin i think
yeah yeah that's what he wants to win
yeah
i left you because he said something in
his last interview and somebody yelled
something from the crowd
and he goes i don't know i think it's 4
20. yeah and everybody kind of chuckled
through the cracks when he smoked weed
on joe rogan oh everybody was like oh
you know your stock's going to drop down
my
stock is going to drop me for them yeah
exactly drop for the day come on man the
whole weed thing is ridiculous
so but there's there's talk now that he
is you know an extraterrestrial guy
and it's no but he's not he uh when
whenever people ask him about
extraterrestrials or ufos or aliens or
whatever he thinks it's bogus
he like brushes it off he's like i don't
even think about that well cause i don't
want to be looking at my genes
i want you to get away from me dude i'm
not gonna believe that
so it's funny that a guy like him
doesn't believe in it he's like he's
like if he's like if you can't find a
a picture or a video that looks like
it's at least shot on a modern day
iphone
he's like you can stop wasting my time
with it yeah
you know i think that's just part of the
property yeah that's kind of suspect
that he's like flying around in space
not like personally but he's got all
this space he's got a car in space
waiting for him
he doesn't believe in aliens i'm not
buying it
there's got to be more to it i mean
there just can't be just us when you
start looking at the bigger picture and
what's really going on yeah
you know of course we talked about this
before i've never had a nightmare
i've never i don't have nightmares now i
couldn't even tell you what a nightmare
is
but when i was like 11 i had something
come in my room one night
and it was more than one they were short
they were small and there wasn't this
big head stuff these kind of look like
this sounds funny it sounded like like a
log
and they had real long flat heads
and i don't know there was probably six
of them maybe they came in my room
i tried to scream for my mom why my mom
i don't know i think he would scream for
your dad in that case but i was gonna
yell for my mom and i still remember
today but i could not get it to come out
and it sounds ridiculous but one of them
put a raincoat on
and was dancing around my bed at it i
mean
what what why would they do that doesn't
sound scientific at all i mean was it
really somebody in my room then i don't
know but it's the only time and here i'm
i'm 60 years old
it's the only dream i ever had that i
still think about
today yeah so you know did i have a was
it a delusion
i do i told you i was wide awake i don't
remember what i did the next day
i don't even remember when i remembered
this i don't remember if i told my
parents about it
but it was definitely one of those odd
things that i you know listen
i've never had a nightmare i don't i
don't have it today i think about this
often
you know but i couldn't tell you hey
yeah by you know it was definitely an
alien
yeah it wasn't anything traditional that
you see or you hear about and i was i
was 11.
so i wasn't really predisposed to even
know about that stuff then
and i wasn't really interested in it
then yeah yeah it wasn't until i was 14
we became a boy scout and we were kind
of you know doing the whole star gazing
thing
that you start asking questions and then
that's crazy that you how you remembered
that for so long
yeah i mean here i am i'm 60 and i was
11. i mean come on so you know again was
it real i don't know but those
are the type of events that start to
form your reality to kind of make you
think okay what's going on here what is
this really all about
the other day that i saw that thing up
up along the radio tower
um looking at that kind of all what the
hell is that i mean
it's got to be something i saw it you
know it wasn't the guy that was abducted
uh in the 70s travis wallace travis
walton travis walton the guy who was
abducted and then
reappear i mean that is also extremely
detailed you know impossibly it's
impossible to cut that
to discredit that story especially of
all the people that saw it well dude the
guys went there
yeah that's why i was showing you yeah
um the interesting thing about him is
he also has similar stories to like your
story about in your bedroom
like he has a story about after he had
kids
that he told that how he woke up out of
a dead sleep
one night running full speed to his
kid's bedroom
like he i don't know how that happens
it's never happened to me i've never
woken up in the middle of night running
but he says he's never slept walked
before and he was running to his kid's
room and he woke up
and he just he finds himself in his
son's room and his son is like
they have the bunk beds and this kid was
like halfway off the bunk bed with his
neck stuck between
the railing so his kid was like a minute
from being suffocated to death wow
and he said he like saved his kid's life
if if he wouldn't got there
five minutes earlier he would have been
dead and see what makes that guy so
credible he has these stories like this
like dude people like him oh his story
is super credible about the abduction
but that story obviously you can't prove
well listen but it's just interesting
that he has those
it wasn't even his story that i heard
that made me go like oh wow it was the
guys who left him there
when they saw that thing grab him and he
was back arch they said where the [ __ ]
out of here man
they left so for me because those guys
were all ashamed of themselves when they
first left him
they didn't they didn't want to tell
anybody they left them yeah they were
all ashamed that they had left him out
there in the middle of this woods
so initially they thought hey maybe
these guys murdered him
and i think he came it was either three
days or six days later when he popped
back up and everything and then all of a
sudden like hey there he is
so to me again very credible when you
talk about betty and barney
yeah again dude very credible
i remember hearing them about them in
the 70s when they first came out with
that whole thing and it was out i think
they came out in the 60s really but
i remember hearing about it in the 70s
and of course being a black and white
couple like that at mixed race couple
the last thing you want to do and
especially in the 70s
is come up with some crazy story to make
you look like some crazy black guy
right right so he stuck to the story
um and then you know as time went on
they were actually bringing more
like he said um one of the odd things
with him wasn't that he didn't
understand originally
because he's still trying to put
everything together was the top of his
shoes
the toes were all dragged through the
shoe it was all they were gone there's
no leather there on the tread that's
very tip of the shoes
and when they put him under um
to talk about the event hypnosis
under hypnosis he said that he floated
up
and as he was going forward he was
dragging his toes along the ground
to the ship and he didn't remember that
until he said it he said oh my god
because he had a picture of the shoes
and she here's the picture of the shoes
she they tried to take her dress off of
her but they didn't know what a zipper
was
so they started tearing the dress and
pulling on it didn't know whether like a
second skin on her or what it was
and so when she got back her dress all
these weird tear marks in it
and their dress is still around i think
the shoes are still around also
i remember the thing that stuck out to
me the most about the betty and barney
story was that
she remembered asking one of the things
that abducted her
where they're she's like where who are
you and where are you from
or where are we and the being responded
to her
like telepathically and said if you
don't know where you are
right now it would be a way it would be
worthless for me to tell you where i'm
from
actually having a conversation right you
know they stuck a needle in their
stomach
yeah and she said she got all freaked
out when that happened because she's
like oh
you know what's this all about and the
guy said to her in his mind hey laurie's
not going to hurt she goes it still hurt
but he was talking to her mentally and
said hey
you know this isn't going to hurt you'll
be okay when it's all said and done
um they took semen from barney you know
he didn't want to tell anybody that
like you know that's weird
how did they take the semester
to tickle the prostate or do you like
this how about that
probably just listen it probably gave a
good shock yeah
they couldn't go like a hand over it
probably like like i said i'd hoping to
never find out personally
don't touch my junk would you what would
you do if you saw if you saw
what travis walton saw if you if you saw
a saucer hovering
50 feet above the ground what would you
run to it and hope that it's
that it vacuums you up or would you what
would you do i definitely wouldn't run
to it i think i would be i would
eventually say to myself
aha i was right i think that's the first
thing i would say but i definitely
i'm too too aware of like radiation and
how these things are flying or
you know when when the one that they had
in britain when the
military but travis they cured him
that's why they pulled him up because he
ran in he hit there he
got hit all that radiation right which
would have killed him sure and his
theory is they brought him up just so
they could fix him and heal him
and then they dropped him back off i
mean listen if they grabbed me it's a
whole other story but if i have
any say so on the matter is i'm gonna be
standing as far away from you as i can
see you're not gonna try to get
beamed up no okay no okay
no yeah beat me up you just want like a
picture and proof
not like i just wanted to wave up me
through the window hey okay
we're good so maybe if i could bring my
gun with me would be okay
yeah do you think that would help you
not really what if you get up there and
then there's like one of those stickers
that says like no guns allowed
i can see that no human guns i can't see
there's some space weed up there
yeah what's that about like some space
drugs it's funny you know i read a story
i wrote a book called janissaries i was
in the navy and it was kind of bizarre
man
it's about a military group they go to
cuba to do this
this uh they're gonna kill like the
leader of cuba it's very classified
they get brought in and they get landed
what they don't realize was they were
just set up and the us was going to
leave them there
and let them get killed and it was going
to be this big you know
crude crawl that was trying to take
place and this is what happened
and so while these these americans are
they're fighting i said dude i don't
think anybody's coming for us i can't
get anybody on the radio
the ship lands and they're all like what
the hell is that he's i don't know man
the door opens up and the voice says
come on let's go the guy's like dude i'm
not going are you gonna stay here
so there's there's this there's this
command argument going on
these guys can get wiped out by the
cubans so they finally decide to get on
this thing and they all get on it they
all jump into it it takes off
and they're all kind of talking to each
other looking around where the hell are
we at
you